commençons
nos collègues vont probablement nous
rejoindre mes chers collègues sur
proposition de madame la Première
ministre le président de la République
envisage de reconduit madame Laurence
boribansel à la présidence du directoire
de la Compagnie nationale du Rhône et
donc par conséquent en application du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution cette nomination par décret
du Président de la République ne peut
intervenir qu'après avis public de la
commission permanente de chaque
assemblée cette audition donnera donc
lieu à un vote à bulletin secret
l'Assemblée nationale vous ayant entendu
hier après-midi nous procédons au
dépouillement simultanément dans les
deux chambres après cette audition il ne
pourra être procédé à cette nomination
si l'addition des votes négatifs dans
chaque commission représente au moins
3/5 des suffrages exprimés au sein des
deux commissions
arrive rarement mais ça peut arriver
voilà mais
bon voilà notre commission est très
attachée comme vous le savez madame la
Présidente à la Compagnie nationale du
Rhône c'est une entreprise forte de 90
années d'histoire un modèle de gestion
publique privé avec des missions
multiples en faveur de la transition
énergétique un ancrage territorial le
long du sillon rhodanien sans plus
tarder je vais céder la parole à notre
collègue Daniel grimillet qui est
président du groupe énergie et qui est
rapporteur sur cette nomination et
ensuite notre collègue Patrick Chauvet
rapporteur de la loi du 28 février 2022
sur l'aménagement du Rhône vous
interrogera également puis je vous
donnerai la parole voilà Daniel
merci Madame présidente
mes chers collègues madame Henri Bancel
nous nous ont disons aujourd'hui sur
votre reconduction en fonction de
présidente du directoire de la CNR créé
en 1933 la CNR s'est vu confié en 1934
la concession du Rhône avec trois
missions la production électricité la
navigation fluviale et l'irrigation
agricole c'est 19 centrales
hydroélectriques produisent un quart de
l'énergie hydroélectrique française elle
est une société anonyme d'intérêt
général à la gouvernance originale 33%
de son capital est détenu par l'État 17%
par les collectivités et 50% par engie
vous avez été désigné en 2021 pour une
durée limitée avant le renouvellement de
la concession par la loi relative à
l'aménagement du Rhône de 2022 raison
pour laquelle nous vous entendrons à
nouveau aujourd'hui à l'époque nous
avions déploré la méthode ainsi choisie
par le gouvernement consistant à
procéder à une désignation temporaire
diplômée de l'École supérieure des
ingénieurs de génie chimique avant votre
arrivée à SNR vous avez effectué votre
parcours dans le secteur du gaz naturel
d'abord chez Gaz de France puis engie
fournisseur de gaz naturel ou chez engie
exploitant de terminaux métalliers
dans ce contexte vous posez je voudrais
vous poser plusieurs questions la
première
concerne votre parcours lors de votre
désignation en 2021 nous nous étions
interrogés sur votre proximité avec le
groupe engie actionnaire quasi
majoritaire de la CNR comment
maintenez-vous dans l'exercice de vos
fonctions aujourd'hui avec ce recul une
équidistance entre tous les actionnaires
la seconde question porte sur votre
appréciation de la loi de 2022 alors que
les concessions hydroélectriques sont
l'objet de contentieux avec la
Commission européenne cette loi a permis
et le renouvellement de celle du fleuve
du Rhône jusqu'en 2041 et la consacré
des missions d'intérêt général
de cette concession ainsi que ces
documents pragmatiques
programmatique pardon
cahier des charges un schéma directeur
des programmes pluriannuels quinquennaux
et des programmes de travaux
supplémentaires et la transférer à la
concession 3000 hectares du domaine
fluvial public depuis voie navigable de
France et lui a appliqué une redevance
progressive allant de 10 à 80% en
fonction du prix d'électricité à
l'initiative du Sénat cette loi a placé
les missions de la CNR sur la voie de la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050 en
promouvant la production et la diffusion
de nouveaux vecteurs énergétique comme
l'hydrogène renouvelable ou bas carbone
et en soutenant l'utilisation de
procédés photovoltaïques innovant comme
la grille voltaïsme ou les panneaux
flottants ou verticaux de plus elle a
permis de renforcer l'association des
collectivités territoriales le soutien
des professionnels agricoles et le
renforcement de la sécurité juridique
quel est votre point de vue sur cette
loi donne-t-elle suffisamment de
visibilité à la CNR ou en est la mise en
œuvre des programmes furoniduels
quinquennaux dont le montant moyen est
de 165 millions d'euros pouvez-vous
présenter les actions et les moyens du
premier plan institués en 2022 et
notamment les investissements prévus en
matière d'hydroélectricité d'hydrogène
et de photovoltaïques où en est
l'application du programme de travaux
supplémentaires prévoyant l'équipement
de barrage ou d'écluses qu'en est-il du
projet d'aménagement hydroélectrique en
suspens de Saint-Romain de Julien et
quel est l'impact de l'extension de la
concession et de l'évolution de la
redevance sur la gestion concrète de la
CNR ma troisième question après à votre
projet quel investissement
envisagez-vous pour le prochain
programme furieux annuel avec un canal
comment intégrerez-vous la baisse du
débit du fleuve Rhône qui pourrait
s'établir entre 10 et 40% d'ici 2050
d'un point de vue plus pratique comment
gérez-vous les effectifs et les
logements de snr la CNR envisagez-vous
de modifier cette gestion
ma dernière question porte plus
largement sur le secteur de
l'hydroélectricité le cadre national
doit-il évoluer je crois que nous
devrions faire davantage en faveur de
cette source d'énergie renouvelable dans
les prochaines lois quinquennales sur
l'énergie et la programmation urinaire
de énergie le cadre européen doit-il
aussi évoluer je crois que le
contentieux européen existant entre en
la matière constitue un frein pour le
développement de la filière française
l'évolution envisagée des concessions du
groupe EDF dont l'institution d'une
régie ou le rachat de propriété vous
semble-t-elle satisfaisante
souhaitez-vous que ces concessions
restent contestables du point de vue du
SNR voilà madame Boris Mancel madame
président de chers collègues les
questions je souhaitais vous poser très
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur cher Patrick Chauvet
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues madame boribans c'est la
monture je souhaiterais vous interroger
sur l'application de la loi de 2022
cette loi est composée de cet
articlesquels ont été annexées à cahier
des charges de 63 articles et un schéma
directeur de City dans le cadre du bilan
annuel de l'application des lois j'ai
constaté que la mise en oeuvre des
dispositions de cette loi était encore
perfectibles au 1er avril 2023 6
articles ont trouvé une application
parmi ces articles quatre sons
d'applications directes 1 a nécessité un
décret et un autre un arrêté en revanche
les dispositions sur le comité de suivi
de l'article 4 ou l'énergie réservée de
l'article 6 ne sont pas pleinement en
vigueur de plus le cahier des charges
comporte huit occurrences à des
modalités d'application réglementaires
en cours de mise en œuvre pouvez-vous
nous dire où en est l'évolution du
comité de suivi qui attend toujours un
nouvel arrêté où en est celle des
énergies réservées par donc
nécessite encore un nouveau décret plus
largement certaines dispositions
législatives ou réglementaires
applicables à la concession
doivent-elles déjà évoluer je vous
remercie voilà madame la Présidente tous
les toutes les questions de nos deux
premiers rapporteurs mais je vais vous
d'abord vous donner la parole bien sûr
pour des propos auliminaires et les
réponses assez première question
et je pense que dans mon propos linéaire
je répondrai à certaines des questions
d'ailleurs
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs
je vous remercie madame la Présidente je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur je
me remercie monsieur le sénateur de vos
mots et d'avoir rappelé les raisons pour
lesquelles je suis devant vous
aujourd'hui
en novembre 2021 vous m'avez fait
confiance en Vous prononçant à une large
majorité en faveur de ma nomination en
qualité de présidente du directoire de
CNR
dans le cadre de l'audition qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui je vous propose de
revenir très brièvement sur mon parcours
puis de vous exposer un bilan de mon
action des 18 derniers mois je
partagerai ensuite avec vous ma vision
de l'avenir de CNR ou comment une
entreprise comme la nôtre peut
s'inscrire résolument dans les objectifs
de transition énergétique fixée tant sur
le plan français que européen je
répondrai enfin évidemment à vos
questions
pour commencer quelques mots sur mon
parcours cela a été dit par monsieur le
rapporteur
j'ai toujours voulu travailler dans
l'industrie et dans le secteur de
l'énergie et après un cursus d'ingénieur
à Toulouse et à Édimbourg j'ai commencé
ma carrière au centre national
d'ingénierie de Gaz de France à l'époque
j'étais d'ailleurs la seule ingénieur
femme
je n'ai ensuite plus quitter le monde de
l'énergie où j'ai conduit différents
projets d'infrastructures en gaz et en
électricité en France et à l'étranger
j'ai ensuite assumé différentes
fonctions de direction générale au sein
du groupe engie ces expériences m'ont
permis et me permettent d'avoir à la
fois un pied dans la stratégie et un
pied sur le terrain
dès ma prise de fonction de CNR je me
suis atelier à finaliser le dossier de
prolongation de la concession les
procédures enclenchées dès 2014 tant sur
le plan français que européen m'ont
permis d'être la dernière relayeuse et
de franchir avec succès la ligne
d'arrivée avec l'adoption comme cela a
été rappelé par le Parlement de la loi
aménagement du Rhône
fruit d'un long travail collectif cette
loi a permis de prolonger le contrat de
concession de CNR jusqu'en 2041 à
l'unanimité de la représentation
nationale qui a donc salué le modèle CNR
je profite de ma présence parmi vous
pour vous remercier mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs qui
nous avaient témoigné votre confiance
cette confiance nous honore mais surtout
elle nous engage
la prolongation de notre concession
s'est inscrite dans un contexte très
particulier
2021 et 2022 ont été marqués par une
succession de crise la guerre en Europe
la crise énergétique les manifestations
visibles du changement climatique et
toujours la covid la crise
d'approvisionnement du gaz en Europe
doubler d'une faible disponibilité du
parc nucléaire français à favoriser
l'envoler des prix de l'électricité à
des niveaux jamais atteints cette
volatilité du marché a eu un impact sans
précédent sur des pans entiers de
l'économie
la sécheresse historique qui a sévit en
Europe est venue aggraver les tensions
sur la production d'électricité en
France mettant également à rude épreuve
nos activités de gestionnaire d'un
fleuve et de producteurs
d'hydroélectricité
plus récemment comme partout à l'échelle
nationale le mouvement social de
contestation de la réforme des retraites
a eu des répercussions sur nos activités
avec notamment l'arrêt du service public
de la navigation sur le Rhône en mars et
en avril de cette année
vous l'aurez compris le modèle si
singulier de CNR a été mis à rude
épreuve au cours des années 2021-2022
mais il a su démontrer sa robustesse
Jean-Pierre maintenant à mon bilan
lorsque je passe en revue c'est déduites
dernier mois trois mots me viennent
naturellement à l'esprit
résilience agilité engagement
comme l'ensemble des entreprises de
françaises nous nous sommes adaptés aux
fluctuations du marché de l'électricité
à l'été 2022 nous avons été contraints
de racheter de l'électricité au prix
fort pour pallier notre déficit de
production hydroélectrique
mais cette en voulait des prix a aussi
permis de démontrer l'efficacité et la
pertinence du nouveau mécanisme de
redevance hydraulique inscrit dans notre
nouveau contrat de concession
je rappelle que cette redevance était
fixe jusque là avec un taux à 24 %, 24%
de des ventesnettes de d'électricité et
cette redevance elle s'appuie désormais
par un site sur un système par tranche
comme les tranches de l'impôt sur le
revenu la tranche la plus basse pour la
partie du prix de l'électricité qui est
inférieure à 26 euros c'est 10%, la
quatrième tranche qui est la plus haute
pour la partie de l'électricité dont le
prix est supérieur à 80 euros par
mégawattheure c'est 80%
ce nouveau mécanisme nous a ainsi
conduit à reverser l'année dernière en
2022 malgré la sécheresse 176 millions
d'euros au titre de la redevance
et j'aimerais souligner que lorsque les
débits étaient au plus bas l'été dernier
nous avons su garantir nos trois
missions historiques
dans le domaine du solaire et de
l'éolien nos équipes ont elles aussi été
impactées par la flambée des prix des
matières premières et par la rupture des
chaînes d'approvisionnement là encore
nous nous sommes adaptés nous avons revu
le design des projets nous avons revu
leur valorisation
pour soutenir l'effort du déploiement du
solaire photovoltaïque dans la vallée du
Rhône j'ai aussi souhaité la création
d'une filiale dédiée elle s'appelle
solarona et elle associe nos partenaires
de la banque des territoires et des
caisses régionales du Crédit agricole
ainsi que bientôt je l'espère les
régions concernées
depuis 18 mois nous avons également été
au rendez-vous de notre activité
industrielle nos équipes ont mené
tambour battants le programme de
maintenance de nos ouvrages
hydroélectriques résultats 99% de nos
groupes de production disponibles au 31
décembre 2022
la loi la promulgation pardon de la loi
aménagement du Rhône a marqué le top
départ d'un programme ambitieux de
travaux pour lequel je demandais aux
équipes de s'inscrire dans un calendrier
d'études et de réalisation volontariste
sans empiéter bien sûr sur les temps de
dialogue et de concertation avec les
territoires conditions sinequanone de la
réussite de nos projets
ce programme chiffré à 500 millions
d'euros en 2018 vise principalement deux
objectifs
développer 100 mégawatts de nouvelles
capacités hydroélectriques sur le Rhône
et renforcer nos infrastructures
fluviales
parmi les projets majeurs sur lesquels
nous sommes déjà à pied d'oeuvre
en effet l'étude d'un nouvel aménagement
hydrolestrique hydroélectrique pardon à
la confluence de l'un et du Rhône
dénommé renergia qui pourrait être mis
en service en 2033 la concertation
préalable sous l'égide de la scène
d'épée qui a désigné quatre garants
au dernier trimestre de cette année
cette concertation comme les études
préalables que nous menons permettra à
l'état de se positionner sur la suite
qu'il entend donner à ce projet
notre contrat prévoit également la
construction de 6 nouvelles petites
centrales hydroélectriques ainsi que
leur 6 passe à poissons ils prévoient le
renforcement des capacités de production
de l'un de nos aménagements existants
l'aménagement hydroélectrique de
Montélimar enfin il prévoit le
doublement des portes avales de 2 de nos
écluses qui permettra ainsi de
fiabiliser la navigation sur le Rhône
je conclurai ce rapide de bilan par les
missions d'intérêt général de CNR auquel
je suis très attaché et qui font
également la fierté de nos
collaborateurs
CNR a lancé en 2022 son nouveau
dispositif de mission d'intérêt général
dénommé le plan 5 Rhône
il est doté de plus de 170 millions
d'euros
et il est entièrement consacré au
développement économique et à la
transition écologique des territoires en
visant à soutenir des initiatives
portées par des acteurs locaux sur cinq
volets d'action j'y reviendrai pour
répondre à monsieur le rapporteur
à travers ce plan c'est l'essence même
du modèle redistributif et de partage de
la valeur de CNR qui s'incarne
j'en viens maintenant à parler de
l'avenir et plus spécifiquement de la
stratégie que j'ambitionne de poursuivre
à travers notre plan stratégique CNR
2030 si vous m'accordez à nouveau votre
confiance
CNR n'est pas une entreprise
industrielle comme les autres c'est une
entreprise industrielle qui a été pensée
et crée pour servir avant tout la nation
et l'intérêt général pour moi cette
raison d'être n'a jamais autant fait
sens qu'à leur ou notre pays doit
relever les deux plus grandes défis de
ces 50 dernières années
décarbonées notre économie
réindustrialisée notre pays c'est
pourquoi j'ai fixé 5 priorités d'action
pour notre projet d'entreprise
la première
sécuriser et moderniser nos
infrastructures industrielles
en tant qu'industriel responsable nous
devons être exemplaires pour garantir la
sécurité de nos collaborateurs ainsi que
celle des salariés des entreprises qui
travaillent pour nous
en tant qu'industriel concessionnaire du
Rhône et pour répondre aux besoins
d'électrification massive du pays des
prochaines années nous devons pérenniser
moderniser nos aménagements dont la
moyenne d'âge est aujourd'hui de 52 ans
pour ce faire nous avons renforcé nos
investissements de maintenance
130 millions d'euros en 2023
90 millions d'euros des années
précédentes
ma seconde priorité d'action ne va pas
vous surprendre nous devons développer
le plus rapidement possible de nouveaux
actifs de production d'électricité
renouvelable
vous êtes bien entendu très au fait des
enjeux relatifs à l'énergie et au climat
l'ensemble des lois discutées et votées
sur ces sujets sont les briques d'un
vaste édifice auquel CNR veut prendre
toute sa part et mon pragmatisme me
conduit à vous dire que les énergies
renouvelables notamment le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien doivent être
développés le plus rapidement possible
pour répondre à la hausse massive de la
demande en électricité car elles sont
aujourd'hui des technologies matures et
compétitives
CNR ambitionne ainsi de développer 1500
méwatts de puissance supplémentaires
d'ici 2030 en éolien et en solaire
je suis convaincue que ce développement
ne sera pas possible sans l'appui sans
l'appropriation des territoires et de
leurs élus
je suis régulièrement au contact des
maires sur le terrain malgré l'hostilité
de certains à l'égard des énergies
renouvelables j'ai constaté que leur
volonté d'être parti prenante des
projets et très forts
je crois beaucoup à l'innovation
technologique l'énergie
osmotique le photovoltaïque linéaire
l'agrivoltaïsme ou encore l'hydrogène
renouvelable font partie des énergies du
foot du futur et je souhaite que CNR
continue à un être un laboratoire pour
leur donner une chance de participer
demain au mix énergétique
autre priorité majeure de mon action
mettre nos ressources de
concessionnaires du Rhône au service du
développement et de la transition
écologique des territoires
en ce qui concerne le transport fluvial
mon ambition sera de dynamiser le trafic
sur la voie d'eau
tout d'abord en optimisant les
interconnexions entre le fleuve et le
rail
ensuite en mobilisant les ressources
foncières de CNR au bord du Rhône au
service de l'attractivité et de la
réindustrialisation de nos territoires
pour cela nous travaillons deux concerts
avec des autres acteurs de l'axe
Méditerranée Rony sonne et notamment le
port de Marseille voit navigable de
France SNCF réseau et les CCI dans
l'objectif d'apporter une solution
cohérente de l'axe
pour ce qui est notre mission pour
l'agriculture les effets du changement
climatique nécessitent que CNR
accompagne les agriculteurs dans la
transformation de leur pratique
l'enjeu est de répondre aux besoins des
cultures sans sur solliciter les
capacités du fleuve et de contribuer
ainsi à notre souveraineté alimentaire
dès cette année nous financerons et
accompagneront par exemple 16 projets
d'agriculture durable à hauteur de 3
millions d'euros qui bénéficieront à une
centaine d'agriculteurs du sillon
rhodanien toutes filières confondues
enfin la préservation du Rhône et de sa
biodiversité en lui redonnant son
caractère vif et courant est aussi dans
l'ADN de l'entreprise et depuis 20 ans
CNR a ainsi engagé le plus important
programme mondial de restauration
écologique d'un fleuve
l'ensemble de ces actions
hydroélectricité navigation irrigation
et biodiversité doit évidemment prendre
en compte la réalité de l'évolution de
l'hydrolicité du fleuve
la récente étude de l'Agence de l'Eau
Rhône Méditerranée Corse qui s'appuie
sur les derniers rapports du GIEC
mettent en évidence que nous serons
confrontés à des phénomènes extrêmes
plus importants à l'horizon 2055
davantage de période de sécheresse en
été
davantage d'épisodes plus vieux divers
moins de neige et donc moins de stocks
d'eau pour le printemps
l'enjeu de la conciliation des usages
doit donc être la priorité de tous et
dans ce contexte le modèle de gestion
holistique du fleuve de Saner prend tout
son sens
pour terminer je souhaite que la
performance irrigue l'ensemble de
l'entreprise tout comme la RSE socle de
mon ambition stratégique ainsi je
n'envisage pas qu'une entreprise comme
la nôtre premier producteur français
d'électricité 100% renouvelable et
engagée dans la RSE ne soit pas
exemplaire en matière de sobriété
énergétique de protection de la
biodiversité mais aussi et surtout
concernant la place des femmes et des
hommes au cœur de l'entreprise
une entreprise n'est rien sans
l'engagement au quotidien et dans la
durée de ces salariés
je continuerai donc à faire de la lutte
contre toutes les disney discriminations
de la féminisation de toutes les
filières y compris technique de la
formation continue et de la qualité de
vie au travail un axe fort de ma
présidence si vous décidez de me la
confier
voici donc en quelques mots les
fondements de ma vision CNR j'espère
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs que mes propos vous auront
convaincus de mon enthousiasme de mon
engagement à faire de cette entreprise
un atout au service de la transition
énergétique et écologique de la France
et de ses territoires je vous remercie
pour votre attention et je vais
maintenant répondre à vos questions
très bien merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente je vais donc ouvrir le débat
merci de vous inscrire sur notre petite
boucle WhatsApp et je vais commencer par
Sylviane Noël
merci madame la présidente madame bourib
Ansel vous le savez le Rhône prend sa
source au sommet du col de la furca dans
le Valais Suisse il traverse la Clément
et reçoit l'eau des affluents alpin et
du Massif central avant de se jeter d'un
Méditerranée parmi ces affluents bon
nombre se situe en territoire de
montagne or les fortes pentes des
versants montagneux entraînent des
vitesses d'écoulement très importantes
et génère une érosion très active des
terrains et le caractère torrentiel des
têtes de bassin versant marqué par un
transport solide conséquent en bloc de
pierre en gravier en bout peut avoir des
incidences non négligeables sur le débit
du Rhône j'aimerais savoir donc quels
sont les actions mises en oeuvre par la
Compagnie nationale du Rhône pour une
bonne prise en compte de ces cours d'eau
située en tête de bassin je vous
remercie
merci Sylviane Henry Cabanel ensuite
Daniel salmon oui merci madame la
présidente madame la Présidente vous
venez de d'évoquer donc une de vos
missions l'irrigation agricole
effectivement vous avez fait allusion
à plusieurs études commandées commandité
par notamment l'agence de l'agence de
prône Méditerrané Corse et vous venez de
le dire avec
donc des craintes
sur le débit du Rhône notamment d'ici
2050 vous venez de confirmer votre
volonté de continuer à accompagner
l'agriculture au niveau donc de
l'irrigation
bon moi j'aimerais bien quand même
comprendre comment vous allez faire
parce que aujourd'hui
l'irrigation au-delà donc
de dérive droite et gauche neurones
l'irrigation de l'eau du Rhône va jusque
dans mon département de l'Hérault donc
très loin du Rhône avec donc une volonté
de mettre en place une rigation économe
mais surtout avec des investissements
lourds notamment au niveau des
agriculteurs et donc je voudrais savoir
dans la stratégie qui est la vôtre
quelle garantie ils peuvent avoir
malgré les difficultés qui s'annoncent à
avoir suffisamment de l'eau par rapport
à leur investissement
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Daniel salmon
merci Madame le présidente merci pour
cette présentation et un engagement non
fin dans la transition écologique
que je que j'apprécie grandement
je reprendrai quelques propos de mon
voisin
il y a les différents usages de l'eau
vous êtes au cœur de ces usages entre la
production électrique l'irrigation
la préservation des milieux la
navigation le tourisme
comment priorisez-vous comment
s'effectue pour vous cette gestion ça me
semble dans le moment où nous sommes
avec les aléas climatiques quelque chose
de fondamental j'aimerais savoir
également quels sont vos relations avec
EDF puisque vous partagez ce fleuve
savoir comment cela se passe et puis
vous avez évoqué l'énergie osmotique
peut-être une énergie d'avenir si vous
pouvez nous en dire un petit peu plus ça
m'intéresse merci beaucoup
je t'en prie oui vas-y à toi
Florence merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente également je vous
avais un projet dans le sud de Lyon qui
pourrait être utile d'ailleurs à la
vallée de la chimie de d'hydrogène
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus
avec le réchauffement climatique la
baisse de rendement des des barrages
notamment et
peut avoir vraiment des effets sur votre
production d'électricité comment est-ce
que vous l'envisagez à court et à moyen
terme et de et deux questions peut-être
qui concernent directement mon
département concernant l'immobilier de
la CNR d'anciens logement qui avait été
fait il y a de nombreuses années qui
aujourd'hui ne sont plus du tout
utilisés et alors que le zan se met en
place il pourrait être de vraies
solutions pour les communes donc est-ce
que vous envisagez de travailler avec
les collectivités sur ce sujet et
également sur un autre sujet de
préoccupation qui est l'envahement des
ports qui ont été
qui ont été créés donc comment
comptez-vous accompagner les
collectivités sur ce sujet
merci Florence y a-t-il d'autres
questions je n'en vois pas madame la
Présidente je vais me permettre de
revenir sur quelques questions qui ont
été posées par nos rapporteurs et sauf
les tours de rythme ma part je n'ai pas
entendu de réponse sur notamment la
question de notre collègue Daniel
grimillet sur les coups distances entre
les actionnaires qui étaient une
question qu'on s'était posée ah pardon
voilà il y a quelques il y a quelques
temps l'appréciation de la loi qui a été
votée notamment la visibilité que cela
donne à CNR le cadre national également
sur l'hydroélectricité est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il doit évoluer les logements
mais je me doutais que Florence allait
poser la question parce que en effet je
me souviens de sa question la dernière
fois également et qu'elle est plus que
jamais d'actualité et mon collègue
Patrick Chauvet vous a posé aussi des
questions sur ce qui reste à paraître
en termes de décret sur la proposition
de sur le projet de loi sur le CNR voilà
peut-être voilà vous bien vous remettre
cela en tête
peut-être commencer par la question de
Monsieur de La rapporteur à propos de
l'équidistance la première chose que je
veux dire c'est que moi mon CAP ma
boussole c'est l'intérêt social de
l'entreprise voilà donc je suis du
dirige une entreprise donc c'est c'est
c'est ça mon c'est ça ma boussole et la
deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
aussi c'est mais vous le savez
évidemment que concernant le capital de
l'entreprise l'entreprise est encadrée
par la loi URSSAF et par conséquent
engie dispose de 49,97% du capital de
CNR et
c'est tout
voilà donc sur
concernant le je pense que donc
concernant le l'ambition de
développement éolien photovoltaïque je
pense que là j'ai pu répondre
à monsieur le rapporteur
concernant le les plans synchrones je
pense que je viendrai après concernant
le la loi et l'application donc la mise
en oeuvre de la de la nouvelle loi
aménagement du Rhône je voudrais évoquer
des comités de suivi de la concession
qui sont
donc des comités qui rassemble les
parties prenantes autour de la
concession et qui ont été mis en oeuvre
dès l'année dernière
dès le mois de novembre si ma mémoire
est exacte et qui se qui se sont tenus
cette année la semaine dernière cette
semaine je crois que le dernier comité
de celui de la concession il est il est
demain donc ce sont vraiment des comités
qui rassemble au-delà de des services de
l'État et de CNR des acteurs des
territoires et des parlementaires ça
c'est la nouveauté de la de la de la de
la loi donc ça je pense que c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est important de
souligner
concernant les les plans synchrones
oui les plantes synchrone donc sont des
sont des donc des plans qui visent à qui
dotent en fait des missions d'intérêt
général sur 54 donc c'est 5 axes sont
les énergies renouvelables non matures
on trouvera notamment l'hydrogène on
trouvera le photovolta itinéaire comme
ça a été rappelé ou l'osmotique les la
navigation
l'agriculture la biodiversité et
l'accompagnement de des territoires et
donc comme j'ai pu le dire le premier
plan synchrone est doté de 273 millions
d'euros
concernant le l'évolution de de
des débits alors moi j'ai commencé par
la question concernant effectivement le
les débits les questions d'érosion les
questions de des actions prises par CNR
sur ce sujet donc il faut savoir que
nous collaborons notamment avec avec les
Suisses
dans des opérations qui sont en fait des
chasses sédimentaires que nous avons
appelé à pas vert donc la première c'est
c'est dérouler enfin la dernière pardon
s'est déroulée en 2021 la prochaine sera
en 2024 ou 2025 mais ce sont des
opérations qui sont donc régulières qui
sont maîtrisées par par nos équipes
encore une fois en collaboration avec
avec les opérateurs suisses
sur sur l'agriculture et sur
le que faisons-nous pour la pour
l'agriculture alors d'abord le plan
synchrone que j’évoquais la le volet
agriculture du plan synchrone du premier
plan synchrone est doté de 27 millions à
quoi vont nous servir ces 27 millions
ils vont notamment nous servir à faire
deux choses la première chose c'est
à réparer à moderniser des réseaux
d'irrigation existants j'ai un exemple
en tête parce que parce qu'on l'a signé
il y a très peu de temps ça c'est un
Ardèche vers Chomérac c'est un réseau
qui que nous allons contribuer à
moderniser et cela va permettre enfin
profiter supplémentaire des racines à
plus de plus de
je crois 300
exploitations agricoles donc c'est un
exemple donc de ce que nous faisons nous
modernisons les systèmes d'irrigation de
manière à ce que chaque goutte d'eau qui
est prélevé dans le Rhône aille bien
jusque jusqu'au plantes et la deuxième
chose que nous faisons c'est que nous
accompagnons les les exploitants les
exploitants agricoles pour
modifier faire évoluer leur manière de
cultiver de manière à ce que ce soit
plus résilient face au changement
climatique nous accompagnons donc un
certain nombre de projets comme j'ai pu
le dire dans mon propos liminaire on a
notamment eu beaucoup de succès pour un
appel à projet que nous avons lancé fin
2022 29 dossiers on en a sélectionné 16
que nous allons accompagner donc là
aussi à hauteur de 3 millions d'euros
donc notre mission de l'agriculture une
des trois missions indissociables de CNR
c'est bien de faire en sorte que
l'agriculture française continue d'être
une une agriculture qui permettra de
nourrir la population
concernant
oui les usages les usages de l'eau et la
relation avec EDF alors je pense que
justement le modèle de CNR à qui on a
confié un fleuve dans son intégralité un
aval du lac Léman bien entendu depuis la
frontière Suisse jusqu'à la Méditerranée
et on lui a confié ce Rhône dans ce que
nous disons ce que nous appelons une
gestion holistique du Rhône la
navigation l'irrigation hydrolaticité
c'est un plus justement parce que nous
sommes capables de de concilier les
usages et d'alerter les parties
prenantes sur la nécessaire conciliation
de ces usages
ce que je voudrais dire aussi c'est que
grâce à l'aménagement du Rhône grâce au
[Musique]
usines barrages que nous avons sur le
Rhône nous avons pu même l'été dernier
au moment de de la sécheresse continuer
à
garantir la navigation on a continué à
garantir le tirant d'eau de 3 mètres sur
le chenal et on a permis que
l'irrigation le long du rang ne puisse
continuer à se faire maintenant le
niveau des nappes phréatiques et ça
c'est lié aux aménagements du Rhône qui
sont en fait des marches d'escalier
jusque depuis les Alpes jusque jusqu'à
la Méditerranée
sur la question de la relation avec EDF
donc la relation avec EDF et très bonne
alors on est en aval dans certains
nombre de barrages d'EDF donc nous
sommes des hydrolyciens qui produisons
de l'électricité au fil de l'eau donc
nous tourbons les les gouttes d'eau que
le que le fleuve veut bien nous donner
nous ne stockons pas enfin nous pouvons
faire du stockage en infras journalier
voir au périmètre de la semaine mais pas
assuré un stockage saisonnier donc nous
nous bénéficions on va dire de de lâcher
d'eau de DF lorsque EDF là je dois en
amont donc je ça se passe très bien nous
collaborons bien sûr avec EDF concernant
le refroidissement des des centrales
nucléaires là aussi il y a des accords
qui existent qui sont mis en oeuvre et
la collaboration se passe très bien
oui une question effectivement sur les
baisses de début du Rhône je voudrais
revenir sur l'étude de l'Agence de l'eau
parce que cette étude donc cette
nouvelle étude de l'Agence de l'eau elle
a des conclusions qui qui nous interroge
qui doivent nous interroger
collectivement parce que si la
conclusion de l'étude et que le débit du
Rhône à l'horizon 2000 2055 ne va pas
diminuer en moyenne
ce début moyen il veut plus rien dire
parce que on aura beaucoup plus d'eau en
hiver et beaucoup moins d'eau en été
avec des étiages qui ont déjà
aujourd'hui diminué si on les compare à
1960 on a déjà perdu en gros 7% à la
montée et 13% à Laval puisque dit
l'étude c'est que l'étiage à Laval au
niveau de l'embouchure il pourrait
perdre encore 20% de plus
donc en fait il va falloir que
collectivement on trouve des solutions
de manière à pouvoir utiliser cette eau
qu'on a entre guillemets en trop en
hiver en été quand on en aura besoin
sur l'exploitation de ces nerf il y a
une question aussi sur l'impact sur la
production de l'électricité bien sûr
s'il y a beaucoup trop d'eau en hiver on
ne pourra pas la terminer parce que nos
aménagements nous avons 3 gigawatts sur
le Rhône voilà on en a pas plus et l'eau
en plus c'est déversé au barrage mais
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que dans le dans la programmation de
notre maintenance bien évidemment nous
faisons le plus gros de nos maintenance
en été au moment où nous avons moins
d'eau donc nous continuerons et nous
renforcerons nos maintenance l'été de
manière à avoir tous nos groupes sur le
pont en hiver quand il y aura de l'eau
une question sur l'énergie osmotique
alors l'énergie osmotique
un nez à ses débuts donc c'est une
énergie qui a été d'ailleurs inscrite
dans la loi d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables nous pensons qu'à les
prometteuses notre terrain de jeu nous
CNR c'est le Rhône et donc nous nous
ambitionnons si tout va bien d'installer
un démonstrateur donc quelque chose de
petit ça fera 100 kW
a le dans la bouchure de Rhône vers
Barcarin et ça devrait être fait à la
fin de cette année ou au début de
l'année prochaine et dans l'énergie
cinétique c'est quoi c'est juste la
rencontre de l'eau douce avec l'eau
salée et la différence de salinité de de
l'eau qui crée de l'énergie et donc il
s'agit de faire se rencontrer ces deux
flux à travers une membrane
osmotique qui est une technologie d'une
start-up qui s'appelle switch et que
nous accompagnons et de cette façon nous
nous pensons que cette technique pourra
s'additionner à d'autres techniques et
constituer le mix énergétique de demain
[Musique]
alors j'avais une question sur le projet
hydrogène sur la vallée de la vallée de
la chimie donc effectivement nous
travaillons sur un projet de
d'électrolyseur pour produire de
l'hydrogène vert qui pourrait être
installé sur notre site de Pierre-Bénite
ou pour aller à la fois accompagner la
décoration de l'industriels et aussi la
mobilité donc ce projet il est il est en
cours d'étude on est on est
encore on va dire à l'amont mais notre
ambition ce serait de le mettre en
service quelque part début 2026 donc ce
serait un projet qui serait modulaire on
commencerait par un petit électrolyseur
et on pourrait ajouter des modules en
fonction de de la demande et et
l'hydrogène est important pour CNR parce
qu'à terme nous voyons l'hydrogène comme
un vecteur de stockage c'est à dire que
bon nous sommes producteur à 100%
renouvelable de
capacité
d'électricité donc nous avons 3 Go 3000
MW de production hydroélectrique
aujourd'hui 1000 mégawatt de production
éolienne et photovoltaïques demain à
l'horizon 2030 on ajoutera 1500 MW
majoritairement du soleil de tirs
solaires un tiers d'éolien mais tout ça
c'est de la production renouvelable et
pas stockable et donc l'idée c'est que
lorsque le système aura besoin
d'électricité du système électrique aura
besoin d'électricité nous produirons de
l'électricité mais lorsque le système
aura moins besoin d'électricité nous
produirons de l'hydrogène que nous
stockerons ou que nous distribuons donc
nous voyons l'hydrogène à la fois comme
un vecteur de décarbonation pour
l'industrie pour la mobilité mais aussi
comme un vecteur de flexibilité pour les
productions renouvelables
les logements la question des logements
alors ce que je voudrais dire je
voudrais dire deux choses premièrement
une chose dont je suis fière c'est que
on a mis à disposition un certain nombre
de logements l'année dernière à des
familles ukrainiennes qui qui sont venus
en France au début de la guerre
ensuite concernant la gestion de ces
logements nous savons que nous pouvons
mieux faire et donc nous avons lancé en
fait une étude globale au périmètre de
l'entreprise de manière à gérer au mieux
possible les logements dont il est vrai
qu'un certain nombre sont vides alors
que à l'heure actuelle dans les
territoires on sait qu'il y a pénurie de
logement donc j'ai bien entendu votre
point madame la signatrice
donc une question où il y avait aussi
une question concernant le nom
européenne et les questions de
concession et de remise en concurrence
des concessions là-dessus je voudrais
apporter une réponse concrète c'est que
dans lorsque nous avons revisité la
stratégie donc vision 2030 l'année
dernière et lorsque nous avons revu nos
ambitions de développement renouvelables
il y a une chose que nous avons enlevé
de nos ambitions c'était 500 mégawatts
de de récupération ou de rachat de
concessions hydroélectrique donc c'était
dans la dans la stratégie précédente ça
n'y est plus donc la remise en
concurrence des des concessions
hydroélectriques françaises ne fait pas
partie de notre stratégie n'en fait plus
partie
et sur la question de de
l'hydroélectricité je voudrais aussi
rappeler que souvent on parle des
renouvelables et on oublie
l'hydroélectricité alors que alors qu'à
date en France 50% de des ENR produites
c'est de l'hydroélectricité donc ça
c'est le premier point et alors qu'il y
a un potentiel alors évidemment il est
pas du tout aussi important que le
potentiel de développement
photovoltaïque par exemple il est pas du
tout aussi important que cela mais il y
a du potentiel et je pense que c'est
important de d'abord de comme nous le
faisons de de maintenir à niveau les
outils existants d'essayer chaque fois
que c'est possible d'augmenter la
capacité des ouvrages existants je les
dis nous le faisons à Montélimar nous
les faisons grâce aux six petites
centrales hydrauliques que nous allons
construire entre le l'embouchure du
Rhône et Lyon mais nous le ferons
peut-être aussi parce que que dans le
cadre de du cahier des charges de la de
la prolongation de la concession nous
sommes tenus de faire une étude que nous
devons remettre à l'État
au plus tard dans dans cinq ans mais
nous la ferons plus vite en tout cas
pour sa phase de faisabilité pour la
mettre à disposition de la de la
concertation sur NRJ et cette étude elle
va elle va elle vise à définir ses oui
ou non il est possible d'augmenter la
capacité des autres ouvrages existants
donc il y en a 19 il y en a un c'est
prévu c'est Montélimar on verra ce qu'il
est possible de faire sur les autres
voilà qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié
si vous permettez madame la Présidente
merci juste une petite question
complémentaire sur le solaire parce que
donc on entend que vous avez des
attentes importantes en termes
d'évolution donc en fait c'est quoi
aujourd'hui le je suis pas territoire du
Rhône c'est quoi le développement du
soleil c'est c'est linéaire là dont on
avait entendu parler biface ou est-ce
que c'est d'autres déploiements au
solaire et puis juste une petite
question parce que moi je découvre
l'osmotique je découvre aussi qu'il y a
quand même un rendement très très faible
donc je sais pas si enfin est-ce que
c'est vraiment une énergie avec un
potentiel ou est-ce que ça fait encore
partie des choses qu'on grandit sans
avoir vraiment de réalité voilà merci
maintenant alors sur le sur le
photovoltaïque en fait
nous développons différents objets donc
effectivement nous avons développé un
démonstrateur photovoltaïque linéaire
aujourd'hui ce n'est entre guillemets
qu'un démonstrateur sa valeur
c'est que en plus comme il est orienté
nord-sud alors que le solaire
photovoltaïque qui produit au maximum
entre 13h et 15 heures là il produit le
matin et le soir donc c'est la valeur de
ce pévinaire et c'est pour ça que que on
a fait ce démonstrateur mais aujourd'hui
on fait du photovoltaïque au sol on fait
du photovoltaïque sur ombrière on fait
du photo
et on fait aussi du photovoltaïque sur
sur les toits et on fait d'ailleurs des
projets de petite taille et c'est pour
cela qu'on a qu'on a créé notre
structure solarona mais qui elle est
comment dire agit uniquement dans la
vallée du Rhône et cela Rena traite des
des petits objets inférieurs à 4 négats
mais ailleurs en France on fait donc
tous les tous les types de solaires
photovoltaïques que j'ai que j'ai évoqué
alors là l'osmotique votre remarque est
très juste l'enjeu du démonstrateur
c'est bien de démontrer que grâce à la
nouvelle membrane osmotique qui a été
mise au point par switch on produit plus
d'énergie que l'on a consomme quand on
pompe voilà non mais c'est très clair et
c'est pour ça que on est on fait un
démonstrateur de manière à alors on le
fait parce que on est convaincu que
c'est le cas évidemment mais on fait un
démonstrateur de manière à montrer que
qu'effectivement c'est une c'est une
filière d'avenir évidemment elle se
substituera pas aux autres filières moi
je suis convaincue qu'il faut de tout
pour faire un mix énergétique et
l'osmose pourra en faire partie
peut-être un complément je vous avais
posé une question concernant l'impact de
l'extension de la concession et de
l'évolution de la redevance sur la
gestion concrète de la CNR et il me
semble que vous avez pas précisé
vraiment quel était cet impact là est-ce
que vous pouvez nous le donner
pour être sûr que je comprends la
question l'impact de de la voulait dire
de la redevance la redevance aujourd'hui
elle est elle est vertueuse puisque
avant donc comme je comme je l'ai dit on
avait une redevance qui était calée à 24
% du chiffre d'affaires net de vente
d'électricité quel que soit on va dire
le prix de l'électricité la redevance
telle qu'elle a été mise en oeuvre dans
le dans la prolongation de la concession
elle est progressive en fonction du prix
de l'électricité donc pour la si le prix
de l'électricité est bas on va dire la
redevance elle est faible si le prix
l'excitait eau ben la redevance elle est
élevée avec une dernière tranche qui est
à 80% pour la partie de l'électricité
qui est supérieure à 80 euros par
mégawattheure et donc cette redevance
elle elle permet de à l'état de capter
la valeur
lorsque les prix de marché sont très
importants et
aujourd'hui ce que ce que je peux dire
c'est que l'estimation que nous faisons
de cette de cette redevance pour 2023
lorsque nous la comparons à la crie la
la alors
marginal qui a été qui a été mise en
oeuvre qui a été voté l'année dernière
on se rend compte que la redevance CNR
en fait elle est elle rapporte plus à
l'état et puis ainsi que la crie donc
c'est c'est
un gage on va dire que la valeur qui est
créée par CNR reste évidemment pour
partie dans l'entreprise mais revient
aussi pour partie à l'état et je
rajouterai que pour répondre aussi à
votre question dans le nouveau cahier
des charges de la concession en plus de
cette redevance progressive
il est prévu une clause de rendez-vous
une cause de rendez-vous en 2028 et en
2034 donc à ces deux échéances on va
comparer le business plan de la
prolongation de la concession avec ce
qui se sera effectivement passé et si on
constate que le chiffre d'affaires
dépasse ce qui était prévu de plus de
20%
le surplus sera partagé à part égale
entre CNR et l'État
évidemment c'est pas symétrique
autrement dit si jamais le business plan
il est moins bon que ce qu'on avait
prévu c'est le risque de CNR
donc je sais pas si ça répond à votre
question monsieur le rapporteur
les 3000 hectares supplémentaires alors
les 3000 hectares supplémentaires donc
effectivement ça ça
peut rapporter de la des contributions
supplémentaires mais c'est surtout des
coûts
et on a notamment récupéré les clouses
d'Arles qui est qui que nous devons
remettre en état ça fait partie du
cahier des charges
et qui sera pris en charge d'ailleurs
par par une des pattes du plan synchrone
mais c'est ce n'est pas le on va dire
l'augmentation de de la
de la de la taille de la concession qui
va qui va générer des revenus
supplémentaires
oui il y a aussi le canal de saviières
qui rentrait dans le dans le périmètre
de la concession et que nous allons là
aussi réhabiliter
Martine Berthet a une question
supplémentaire merci madame la
présidente madame boribansel sur les 5
axes du plan synchrown vous nous avez
pas ou alors juste un peu maintenant
parler du de l'axe territoire
pouvez-vous nous donner son évolution
merci
donc dans l'axe territoire on a
notamment
on va notamment continuer à soutenir la
vie Arona on va continuer à soutenir les
investissements des territoires qui
veulent réhabiliter la la connexion de
des villes des villages au fleuves
dont réhabiliter des berges
mettre en place des passerelles
on a aussi
prévu de d'accompagner ça a été dit tout
à l'heure des des dragagements
donc voilà des exemples de ce que de ce
qu'on a pu faire sur de ce qu'on a prévu
de faire dans le dans le plan synchrone
qui qui commence
et le pardon et la pâte donc la pâte
accompagnement des territoires
représentent 35 millions d'euros sur le
premier plan synchrone
pas qui doit prouver que vous avez été
parfaitement clair
je l'espère parfaitement clair donc il
me reste à vous remercier madame la
Présidente nous allons vous raccompagner
procéder au vote donc je demande à tout
le monde de rester bien évidemment on va
vous distribuer des bulletins de vote
sur lequel vous mettez oui ou non voilà
et nous préviendrons nos amis députés
pour que le dépouillement ait lieu en
même temps j'ai besoin de deux
assesseurs
[Musique]
voilà au hasard
Daniel et Bernard allez voilà parfait ah
oui la parité je suis là
voilà
merci beaucoup madame la présidence
merci beaucoup et à très bientôt